c'est un honneur pour moi de te remettre
ce cadeau trois jours à l'hôtel
normandie qui croit que ça va les faire
plaisir peu cadeaux ou leucate d'eau
ce mec c'est la classe incarnée
il va lui offrir une jolie histoire sans
lendemain
bon on peut aller boire un verre sur m6
crouy va se transformer en princesse
il lui jouera la rencontre par hasard et
il va la faire tomber dans ses bras
comme ça si je puis me permettre
vous êtes assis sur une chaise des
roches mixant sur la chaise de qui mais
c'est quoi la c'est la biennale des
lourds dingues ou quoi
djoko ob c'est direct ah non mais c'est
pas vous séparer de votre truc vous êtes
spécialiste en gastronomie romantique
pourquoi il tourne sa tête commence à
être un problème à la nuque et à la
mâchoire aussi en colère je crois je
suis tombé remet en moins c'est
peut-être un petit peu tôt pour parler
d'amour non tu es en train de faire le
coup de la panne on dirait une deuxième
qui précède ce faire culbuter à
l'arrière d'une r5 la mare chérie tu vas
rire le type que tu as rencontré hier
soir c'est parce que tout ce que tu
crois en fait il ya ça j'ai rencontré un
homme par hasard pour comment s'appelle
et à tout l'entraînement fin par hasard
alice je m'appelle hélène c'est bien je
peux retourner le problème dans tous les
sens sont d'alerté elle a quitté l'hôtel
précipitamment pourtant il avait tout
d'un homme charmant 10 tonnes du chat on
tutoie déjà ponctué choquant non bah oui
tout cas j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle je commence par la tête bah oui
c'est normal